I moved to New York City and I lived
with Sean puffy combs for a year that's
the crazy thing now that was la Reed's
idea right we're sending you over to
something called puffy flavor camp eager
to learn some yeah that's what it was
called and you're gonna go to puff
daddy's he's given in 90s do you
understand what that's like Puffy's
place was like just filled with chicks
and origin like non-stop right not
really
but did air a it was curious I got a
chance to see some things yeah but we 13
what we went there to see the lifestyle
right and I saw in us anyway but I don't
know if I could indulge and understand
what I was even looking at it was it was
pretty wild
so nobody tried to you know some woman
didn't come along say okay I understand
what I did say is that there were very
curious things taking place
uh-huh and I didn't necessarily
understand yes biggie smalls was there
smalls was there little Kim Craig Mac
all these people are hanging around here
man Faith Evans Jodeci Mary Jay blush
they learn about this [ __ ] oh I was
having a good time does he have you
doing any chores are you doing dishes at
all I'm you need to keep you humble
somewhat or are you just like can you
stay up to 4:00 in the morning with them
a party I mean I could actually stayed
up longer than them do you have money
and what's going on I mean I had like
per diem yeah I had like you know what a
living yeah it's pretty crazy 14 years
old you're a dad now would you ever send
your kid to puffy camp yeah